nobody really knows how the wall was
built yes every child hears how in the
days of the first man Brandon the
Builder raised the wall with magic and
giants and set the Nights Watch to
garden but nobody thought to write down
the story until thousands of years later
and the septons who did it weren't much
for accuracy I mean they have knights
bumbling around thousands of years
before they were knights sorry
bad happy but even if magic and Giants
built the wall
it's the Nights Watch you have held it
our order of builders repairs the keeps
and towers digs tunnels
crushes stone for roads and footpaths
and clears away trees wherever the
forest presses too close to the wall or
at least it would if they had the men
when the tools and the time long ago
when the Nights Watch was at full
strength the builders would quarry
blocks of ice from the frozen lake to
the haunted forest traveling them south
on sledges to add to the wall now it's
all they can do to watch for cracks or
signs of melt and make what repairs they
can't without men or tools or time the
order of Rangers is the fighting heart
of the Nights Watch
they ride beyond the wall fighting and
trading with wildlings surviving
shadowcats and snow leopards the Rangers
are meant to scout out threats to the
wall and return to report and they did
back in the days when men could go north
and come back alive now they just come
back the order of stewards keep the
watch alive we hunt and farm 10 the
horses milk the cows gather firewood
cook the meals and bring supplies from
the south not so heroic I know but since
the Nights Watch doesn't starve or
freeze
I guess we're the only order that still
does everything it's supposed to without
all of us guard in the wall together
well they probably still wouldn't have
ever fallen solid ice rise in hundreds
of feet into the air and run in hundreds
of miles to the sea no Army is smashing
it any time soon which is why our
enemies have never tried well not
directly
the brothers gendell and gone kings
beyond the wall went under the wall
through ancient caves buried deep in the
earth but on the way back they took a
wrong turn and were lost in the darkness
people say that their children's
children's children are still down there
looking for a way he'll offer more food
to find its way down when our range has
found arson ice axe picking away at the
wall he was almost halfway through the
Rangers decided not to disturb him and
sealed the way behind him with ice and
stone and snow some say if you press
your ear flat to the wall you can still
hear awesome chipping away with his axe
a hundred years ago another
king-beyond-the-wall Raymond red beard
realized the wall sizes brought its
greatest strength and its greatest
weakness he waited for our patrols to
pass and then sent climbers to the now
unguarded stretch of the wall when they
reached the top they drop ropes and
ladders for thousands more wild uns to
clamber up the Nights Watch didn't even
know his army had crossed until after
the Starks and numbers had collared and
destroyed him and that was a hundred
years ago when the watch had many more
men than now looky for the Nights Watch
the wall isn't without its own defenses
besides being incredibly tall and thick
the wall is also treacherous many times
a patrol will find a broken corpses of
wildlings who've tried to climb the wall
only for a piece of it to break off mid
climb or to have their hold slip as the
Sun melted the ice just enough when the
light strikes the wall just right it can
even look like it's weeping a thousand
years ago the Nights Watch could have
lined up shoulder to shoulder along the
wall all the way from
eastwatch-by-the-sea to the shadow tower
to meet Mance Rayder and his army but
now mance isn't bothering to find
tunnels under the wall or climb over it
he was a sworn brother once he knows
that the glory of the Nights Watch is
behind us mance is going to try what no
man ever has he's going to come through
the wall one day I hope maesters write
stories about how we beat him back
because if we don't there may not be any
more stories to write